you've probably heard about spider-man
demon souls and assassin's creed
but what if i told you the one must play
title for ps5's launch lineup
is actually a game all ps5 owners get
for free
that's right astros playroom is a
wonderful adventure packed with
playstation nostalgia
and it's an absolute must play for
sony's new system
people of the internet's retroarching
tour here if we're meeting for the first
time
i'm just a dad who loves games and the
stories they tell
we post videos every week here on
youtube and also stream over on twitch
we've been covering games here like
animal crossing and hogwarts legacy but
today is
all about astros playroom for the ps5
the playstation 5
is finally here at least if you can find
one that is
and while games like demon souls and
spider-man miles morales are sure to be
system sellers
you absolutely should not overlook
astros playroom
in short this game completely blew me
away it's also been great for my
six-year-old son who's a huge fan of
mario games
this is really his first introduction to
the world of playstation and to be
honest i
can't think of a better way for a kid to
learn all about playstation for the very
first time
in fact i love this game so much i think
it's the first one you should play
on your new system and that's exactly
what i told my wife's cousin when i
mailed his ps5 to him this week
that's right i actually got two ps5
pre-orders in somehow
you can check my twitter for details if
you want that story but i
tell you that so you know i'm not just
saying that for this video
that is real advice i gave someone play
astros playroom before
anything else on your ps5 in fact you
know what let me know your pre-order
story down in the comments below have
you tried
to pre-order a ps5 or xbox yet have you
been
successful in getting either of them
because
sadly it looks like a lot of people are
being left out to dry right now but let
me know
if you've had any luck you guys may
remember the playroom back
in 2013 on the ps4 astro was in that as
well
it's made by the same team and while it
was a fun little experience to show off
the ps4 camera frankly it was
really just that you actually couldn't
even play it at all without the camera
accessory
so i'm sure there's a large number of
people who never played it at all
because of that i can see how easy it
would be for new ps5 owners to maybe
overlook astros playroom
you should know though this time the
camera is not required to play the game
and you have
everything you need right inside the ps5
package
it just requires the new dual sense
controller and then the game itself will
be automatically installed on your
system
so what exactly is astros playroom if
this has been flying under your radar
well it's a
3d platforming adventure that will take
you through the history of playstation
you can probably beat it in about three
hours if you're really pushing and then
maybe four
to six somewhere in there if you're
trying to explore and see everything
it also serves as an incredible showcase
for the new dual sense controller
and i have to be honest with you guys i
never expected to be this blown away
by a controller the last time i remember
having this feeling with the controller
was back with the nintendo wii
and coincidentally it's pack in game wii
sports
now astro isn't likely to make
grandmothers run out to buy a ps5 or
have that same incredible mass market
appeal that the wii did
but for anyone who considers themselves
to be a fan of video games and you enjoy
playing on traditional controllers then
you absolutely have to
experience the duel sense it is truly
mind-blowing
it's really quite a shame that we can't
all just go out right now and try this
out in stores thanks to the ongoing
pandemic situation
but here's what really surprised me is
that i knew
going in okay astro is gonna be a
showcase for the playstation controller
the new dual sense i get that
but i didn't really expect it to be such
a phenomenal game around it
you'll move about a series of different
worlds that represent
generations of playstation consoles
astro will take on various enemies and
platform challenges along the way
you'll have a simple punch attack spin
attack and a laser when astro hovers to
help you take care of the enemies
there are plenty of collectibles to find
in each world as well
the two collectibles are puzzle pieces
and artifacts
the puzzle pieces you find are added to
a giant puzzle in the game's hub area
whereas the artifacts are pieces of
playstation's history that also make
their way
into the hub and if you're wondering why
i'm not showing any footage of the
puzzle pieces and of the artifacts i
think it's
gonna be much better honestly if you
discover this stuff on your own it's
it's
super fun to see all the little details
in there one of my favorite things is
when my son was playing and he'd unlock
a new artifact and kind of give that
look of of what in the world is this
and then i would get to launch into a
story explaining like oh yeah i remember
when i bought this and when we were
hanging out at fred's birthday we played
that it's just there are so many moments
like that especially if you're
kind of around the age i am right now
maybe you remember the original
playstation you've got kids of your own
now
that is uh it's just so many great
stories that came out of that
i would argue that it's all of those
tiny little details of the nostalgia
that
really helped put this game over the top
there's so many little nods and secrets
that i just
frankly don't want to spoil them here
it'll be far better for you to
experience it yourself
it will only take you about four to six
hours to complete all the levels and
gather
all the collectibles as i said in the
beginning honestly that's
probably the only problem i had with the
game i wish it was longer
after it was over i wanted even more
both my son and i were kind of sad to
see it come to an end but what an
incredible ride it was along the way
hopefully this is only the beginning for
astro on ps5 i would honestly
love to see a sobe team get a shot at
making a full length
3d platformer even one featuring astro
as always guys thank you so much for
watching
i'll talk to you again soon